[Music]
foreign
one two three
oh let me get a little
a little Focus going
let me go
Focus going
there we go oh now you can see all my
pores look at that
um
all right
oh my gosh
you know what time it is my friends
we about to get litty
we about to get litty we we about to get
litty
as you can see by the logo here my
friends
we are about to do our monthly hundred
dollar joke contest
that is correct yes it does deserve
Applause perhaps another
yes indeed
as Peeps are coming in here
coming in here
Pizza come in here
come in here pizza coming here
very nice
all right oh we already had 21 people
oh my gosh
[Music]
as we say here what goody what's goody
goody fam
I think so turn that down
what goody there it is all right
I see all of y'all this morning we
already have Ed in here and Alvaro and
Bob and DC it's so great to
see all of you this morning oh my gosh
this is so exciting we do this every
single month my friends
this is our hundred dollar joke contest
our finalist this month
of the month of October
looky there two of them may be familiar
faces well really all three of them
are familiar faces all three of these
peeps have won this contest before
last month two of these peeps were
actually in the finals Bob Kirk and
Sandy Bernstein were actually in last
month's finals
and if you're watching out there and
like oh man I'd like to compete in this
contest oh man I'd like to win a hundred
bucks and an episode on hot breath well
the way you do it
is you join our comedy writing Master
Class
and then every month students of that
class compete in a monthly competition
where I post a secret theme and then the
students get two weeks to write a new
90-second set
well that is loud
we'll go ahead and adjust all those
see the music picked up as soon as I was
like yeah let's get into the groove here
so yes all students of our comedy
writing Master Class
contest
so it's a great place to
if anything just write new material
and then maybe make a little moolah
as well one moment my friends
as we coming in here where y'all
watching from where y'all at
because I'm going to paste the link if
y'all do want to join our comedy writing
Master Class
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
okay okay
hey hey
there we go
wow cool I just pinned that to the live
chat on YouTube oh my gosh we have
Phyllis in here good morning and good
luck Bob Sandy and Jack oh
Jerry Kroll good to see you my friend
Dano
[Music]
says good morning oh this is gonna be a
goodie for shizzle
this is gonna be a goodie for chisel
Jesse watching from Ottawa good to see
you Jesse
we got Alvaro and Montreal
Jerry and Phoenix Dano and Duluth we all
over the map fam
we got Jack Allen checking in here one
of our finalists for this month show
we're about to get into it my friends
we about to get into it
just right about meow
meow hey
[Applause]
boom all right my friends the music has
stopped the party is beginning let me um
I have a lot of focus back here let me
let me adjust the focus a little bit
the only Annoying Thing
is um I have to put it in Focus
literally every single time
it doesn't remember
uh the settings to be in Focus so I have
to adjust it pretty much every single
time we go live which is twice a week
on Tuesdays at five we do joke feedback
and then on Wednesdays at 10 A.M we do a
live joke writing contest and then every
uh once a month we do this joke writing
hundred dollar contest so
a lot cooking my friends
Lynn Biden said good morning from
Toronto good luck oh man
Toronto
I'm gonna go to Toronto I definitely
want to get up to Toronto
but in the meantime in between time my
friends we are about to do the contest
it is so exciting oh my gosh we started
this during the pandemic and it is just
taken off
Comics all over the world competing
and today
my friends already showed you the
finalists I already showed you the
finalists for October right yeah
Sandy Bernstein Jack Allen and Bob Kirk
how this is gonna work
my friends
how this is gonna work is we are going
to watch all three finalist sets these
have been hand selected
I just want you to know by my wife and I
we watch all the contestants
and then we pick our top three
and then
you the viewer today
gets to see the top three sets and you
the viewer gets to vote live on the show
for who wins the 100 bucks and a live
interview today
on hot breath my friends
so there's a lot happening here and yeah
Alvaro said
Bob up there again yeah yeah yeah listen
all three people in the finals this
month
compete every single month
um
it was a close one too man and even
looking back it could have gone
it could have gone a few ways there were
a few up there in the top but
alas these three are the finalists some
ogs and the hot breath of Earth here
they compete every single month which is
a big part and a big reason
of why they are in the finals because
they are consistently writing they are
consistently competing
which consistently gives them a chance
to
win the contest so without further Ado
my friends what's goody all right all
right
it's time to get into it it is time to
get into it oh and Jerry said I heard
pre previews of Jack and Bob setz and
Jones Monday writing room
I knew they were going to be finalists I
almost didn't submit but I knew I needed
a good writing exercise for myself yes
indeed competing in this is great
writing exercise and Jones writing room
she does
oh
Joan was um
I don't know looking back I was like
Joan
I mean
she's gonna very well easily been in the
finals
um
but the finalists have been announced
and the finalists are here today and
what you're gonna do is watch all three
final sets and then you're gonna vote
live on the air today for who wins
the October 100 joke contest so thank
you all so much good to see Evelyn
sneaking in here it's Akuma good morning
to you as well
and now
without further Ado my friends the
running order is going to be Sandy
Bernstein
Bob Kirk and Jack Allen we are going to
watch each set and then bring the winner
on
for a live interview my friends so let's
get into it good to see you here Pete
looky here we got Pete popping in here
we are just about to start
and as we say here let me see if I can
find it
one second
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning Mookie
mookie in the building
we were just about to rumble my friend
the first setup is going to be
Sandy Bernstein my friends so prepare
yourselves
and let's get
I should say as you're watching these
sets the theme is change so with that
theme
watch these sets
and as you think about who you want to
vote for look at not only how funny the
set is but also how creatively
they use the theme of change so look at
it two ways here okay how funny is the
set how many laughs does a set have but
then also
how do they use the theme of change to
make it uniquely theirs and I think
you're going to be pleasantly surprised
as these are the finalists so these are
the best of the best in this competition
if you do want to compete in next
month's competition I put a link to our
comedy writing Master Class
in the live chat
we can join that and join this contest
next week so you can win a hundred bucks
an interview on the podcast
but until then
let's officially
started off
Say it With Me Now
let's get her ready
first up
we have the one we have the only
the Sandy Bernstein
I love change so much
I even changed my underwear since the
Bush Administration
the first bush
speaking of change my company suddenly
laid off 43 workers that day I bet a
bunch of underwear got changed
now my boss wants me to become a change
ambassador to boost morale in the ranks
that makes a lot of sense
that makes as much sense as the proud
boys catering a bar mitzvah
my boss loved that no he made me take a
training module on the four stages of
change management
they are denial resistance exploration
and acceptance
gee that doesn't sound at all familiar
does it
that's nothing like the five stages of
breathing
otherwise it would have included the
most important one
depression hmm
the training then talked about how a
growth mindset Embraces change
and I found myself developing a growth
mindset
I was growing more pissed off by the
minute yeah I got my panties in a wad
then I couldn't wait to change them
after that my boss asked me for my two
cents I tossed him a quarter and said
you can keep the change
oh my gosh
[Applause]
there it is there it is my friends the
first
competitor
Stanley Bernstein
coming in hot there coming in hot
we got some laughy emojis coming in here
already yeah yeah yeah
good use of the word change you can see
she very she used a very personally and
specifically in a lot of different types
of chains she tapped into there so very
cleverly written
love on lockdown said love the Strong
Finish
it's Akuma said that's great
uh Evelyn like the first Bush very funny
Tim King coming in with the Applause
Dano liked it Mookie
given Applause
it said great job Cindy loved to keep
the change in proud boys at the bar
mitzvah
yeah yeah yeah
Lynn said great Sandy with two
exclamation marks that means she means
business there
Jerry liked it in Dede indeedy
very nice yeah hey now that's that's
just the first one now that's just the
first one now
we got two more we got two more here
Jack liked it as well and Bob said nice
when Sandy five steps of grief proud
boys very nice
OMG
well done there Sandy we kicked it off
strong there we kicked it off strong
but to last we have two more before we
do the live voting and we bring the
winner on live on the show today so
Phyllis said great job Sandy still love
coming in for you there Sandy that's
gotta feel good
the hard work paying off
you well done Sandy
all right
well we have seen Sandy my friends and
now
we have two more for you today so thank
you wherever you're watching this from
thank you so much for spending your
Sunday with us we really do appreciate
it we do this every single month and
it's always a Dandy old time
and now without further Ado my friends
next up
we have the one and only Bob Kirk my
friends so prepare yourselves oh looky
there
all right so we're going from Sandy
to Mr Bob Kirk my friends so without
further ado
ladies and gentlemen
prepare yourselves
for
the one
the only
the Bob Kirk
[Music]
two
Bob Kirk change oh did you know there
are 175 different iterations for the
word change and we're going to cover
each and every one of them here today
never say to your girlfriend I'm looking
for change I did that once the world's
almost my last words I quickly said I
was a little change you know in the
couch cushions where I'll be sleeping
tonight I like my women like my change
loose no oh who's more likely to change
their mind a man or a woman I'll tell
you when I get the notification from
Myrtle anytime now I can change my mind
change my opinion but if I change my
heart that's called a transplant people
oh it's really hard sometimes to change
someone's mind but I find that cash
works yeah I have a GPS great with
directions all knowing guides me to
where I need to go
GPS
girlfriend in passenger seat
change or not to change
I'll let you know when I get the answer
still no notification aren't changing
cancel culture the same thing because
when you're canceled your life is
changed remember when I first started
going out I asked her is there a high
turnover rate in your relationships and
she said
oh
that's her notification oops plans have
changed gotta go bye
Bob Bob Kurt
[Applause]
give it up for Bob o there
applause applause applause
no it's Akuma set I think all three of
these comedians would make a great show
oh for sure that would be fun
for sure
you're being an international show too
Sandy's here in in the U.S Bob's up in
Canada and Jack is across the pond so
be an international show
[Applause]
nope
Pete like the loose change
let me see here
Dan said great fun
Pete liked the Loose Change alvado said
nice Bob
Ed said
love my women like I like my change
loose
very funny Jack said smooth finish Lynn
loved the energy there Bob
yes indeedy
got some comments coming in our Facebook
group Sandy said love the GPS line
Mike Mike Marr giving some smiley faces
very nice
Evelyn said I'll let you know when I get
the notification she liked that one
Tim great energy hope said good job Bob
oh that rhymed hope
nice Jack like the loose line Dino GPS
standard feature in any relationship
DC fabulous Bob off the charts Kathleen
Kathleen loving it
given the laughy Emojis
John great great Bob and other great
joke Phyllis Bob likes loose women
kakuma said George Carlin Vibes but
original oh
how fancy
Bob with an attack of jokes again says
Jerry
oh yeah baby
oh yeah
a lot of good love coming in I love it I
love seeing the love
and I don't want to give anything away
Bob did win last
last month's contest all right all three
of these contestants have won before but
did Bob did win last month
um so we shall see if he will repeat but
that being said my friends we still have
one more now we've seen Sandy
we've seen Bob but we do have
uno mas
Amigos
people love the loose women one there
Bob
living
fast and free out there
oh yeah
oh and people wondering
I just saw
Ola embre asked how can people get that
mug Joel well I will put a link to it
in the live stream here if anyone is
looking to um
get their own hot breath mug
we'll try to do a sound effect there but
it didn't work
there it is
yes indeedy and it says on the back
the coolest mug for the hottest podcast
no big deal no big deal
yeah pull up we got shirts and hoodies
and all sorts of fun stuff over there
oh my gosh and what we do have right now
my friends
is one more contestant before we do our
live voting oh my God
oh my
gosh it's happening it's happening
so we've seen Sandy
we've seen Bob
and now solamente uno mas Miss Amigos so
remember as you're watching look at how
funny the set is and also how they use
the theme change this month's theme is
change how cleverly they use the theme
within their sets and now
we're going to change
scenes to our final
contestant of
the day my friends and it is the one
it is the only
it is the Jack Allen
prepare yourselves
oh boy
I'm never fearful of change unless it
involves my mum's hormones
she's getting to
menopause age or even the vacuum is
scared of her
but I've been doing my research
and I had no idea there were symptoms of
menopause is
calling Jack a [__]
you know I had to buy an umbrella just
to Shield myself from the aggression
but I know she'll get over it eventually
all it would take is time medication and
all my self-esteem yeah
you know my friends have babies now yeah
and those babies are already taking on
huge responsibility imagine being the
only thing keeping mummy and daddy
together
but my friends love spending time with
their children I love being with them
that's why they spend all their time
at the pub with me hmm But I can imagine
the joy of looking down at your newborn
baby and just thinking oh
you were created out of sheer fertility
panic
you know a lot of my friends use
Facebook memories to repost pictures of
their wedding day no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I'm sorry you've
had your socially sanctioned dopamine
Spike now even move on or try heroin
oh
that it is my friends there it is
Mr Jack Allen my friends oh mookie
thrown in the um
laughing emojis imbre said haha that was
awesome yeah
[Applause]
yeah everybody showed Jack some love
there let's get let's get Jack some love
going there fam
[Music]
and this is not easy Mike Marr threw in
some laughy emojis
showing love there yeah this is not easy
my friends all right to write a new 90
second set in two weeks it sounds easy
on the surface and then you get into it
and you're like oh this is hard and
they're like oh this is hard
to write a 90-second set in two weeks oh
this is hard to then edit it down this
is hard to then film it like every step
of this takes a lot of work so I
appreciate everyone that does commit to
it and all the feedback I get from the
contest set
is like that people get a lot out of it
even if they don't win they still get
new material they can do on stage so it
is a very productive way to hold
yourself accountable to write
daily which we all strive to do
and Ed said great job Jack
Dano with the thumbs up Imlay said great
physical comedy when he threw the baby
yeah yeah
hope with the laugh emojis Phyllis said
Jack good set but no changing the baby's
nappy
Bob Kirk nice job Jack great job shield
with the umbrella
Evelyn said the vacuum is scared of your
mom very funny Sandy loved your take on
menopause birth and marriage and the
power of Threes ending in your
self-esteem had me rolling
oh
Alvaro
said the international Jack Lynn Biden
funny Jack Dino Jack is funny and wise
Beyond his years yes he is he's a young
chap but he is very funny
um
Phyllis said good set but no changing
the baby's nappy yes
Jerry liked the fertility panic
lots of great jokes Pete like the
dopamine Spike description yeah
Evelyn said it'll cost me all my
self-esteem yeah that was a funny line
too
oh Jack said thank you so much massively
appreciate it I don't know why I did it
in that accent
massively appreciate it
yeah as Alvarez said performing in front
of the camera so hard you don't get the
audience feedback yeah it's
it's tough It's it is not easy
it is not easy
and it's not easy to pick a winner but
alas we have arrived my friends I'm
about to post the poll
on uh YouTube live stream
and the poll is live my friend so it is
now up to you
to pick who wins and this is a lot of
there's a lot at stake here okay they
win a hundred bucks and an interview on
hot breath so there's a lot at stake
here
so for the next minute or so
let's get the beat up a little bit
[Music]
I ain't bad anybody
how about this one
oh Tim King said great job yes indeedy
is now time to vote Jesse said so hard
to choose
it is but alas there could only be one
so get sin
and if you're watching this like oh man
I would love to compete in next month's
contest all you gotta do
all you gotta do all you get to do you
should say is join our comedy writing
master class which I pinned the link
for the top of the live stream on
YouTube
where you can join the writing class
and you get automatically entered into
this contest every single month
and in the early in the early lead we
have Bob Kirk coming out the gates hot
is he gonna repeat is he gonna repeat
I don't know we'll give the voting
another minute here
and for everyone watching
on Facebook the voting poll is on
YouTube so I see Mike asking
see Mike and AJ asking
the voting poll is on our YouTube live
stream
so I will paste the link to it
in the Facebook live chat so y'all can
jump on over to the YouTube
to uh do your voting there
kaboom
oh and Daniel said all made me laugh
yeah yeah that's hey that is that is the
goal that is for shizzle
the goal no dizzle
yeah they're all funny these were
hand-picked
okay these were hand-picked
my wife watched all the submissions
and it came down to these top three it's
Akuma said all of them are great yep
they were
but
love on lockdown said tough choices
always great job everybody yes indeedy
but as we're coming in here to the home
stretch
man oh man
it's looking
Memento Mis Amigos
as we're coming in here
it may be a bit of a landslide here it's
looking
it's looking
it's looking like Bob may run away with
this my friends it looks like Bob Kirk
58 percent
56 percent
after 25 votes we have Bob Kirk in first
Sandy Bernstein in second and Jack Allen
and there it is it looks like that's
that's it I think
I think it's official I think Bob Kirk
has officially won this month that is
two in a row
my friends
[Applause]
in a row
oh Mike said
nice job Sandy Bob and Jack yeah show
love for everyone all right sure love
for everyone that competed in this
contest because it is not easy my
friends it is not easy Evelyn said
congratulations Bob oh yay
and Pete said we don't like change
Alvaro
GG everyone
I guess that means good going everyone
but I don't want to just I don't want to
glance over
Pete may have the comment of the live
stream here we don't like change
because the theme was changed
yeah very well done there Pete very well
done
[Music]
Dano is clapping
Dino said congrats to all the finalists
yes indeedy
oh good game says Alvaro very nice
[Music]
so Bob I just sent you the interview
link I know it takes you time because
you gotta go get on your other
oh
he's gotta go get on his other computer
bow
Sandy congrats Bob and Jack
yes
indeed it was it was good it was a good
competition
it was nice and close
Jerry said congrats Bob do the rest of
us get a participation trophy
sure if you participated in the contest
congrats to everyone that did
participate this month
it's Akuma so we have to start calling
him Bob Koozie because he keeps winning
Bob cowsey
damn
that was a close one the salute to
everyone
that did compete
in this competition a salute to the
finalists you all did great
it's always fun doing this every month
oh my gosh it's such a great way for us
to all come together every month
we do two live streams a week on this
YouTube channel as well on Tuesdays we
do joke feedback
and on Wednesdays I do a live joke
writing contest called the write 10 Club
oh Jerry said Bob Koozie is an old-time
basketball star oh well how could I not
I have known that deep cut oh my gosh
[Music]
oh Tim said very cool
Tim said
I've watched the comedian interviews
first time watching this contest cool
you're doing this well thank you Tim
yeah man we do this every single month
so uh come on back hang out
we're doing a lot of cool things to help
Comics level up their game so it's great
to uh have you join us today here Tim
and we are about to have
Bob Kirk join us in just a moment as
well
oh my gosh he's about to join us my
friends
momento
here we go
let me stop the song oh
all right and this is going to be on the
podcast my friends so let me give him a
proper intro
as we are coming in here
oh what is goody hot breadthiverse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I
am your host comedian Joel Byers and
today's episode is our monthly joke
contest and our winner this month was
last month's winner which means you won
100 bucks and an interview
on the podcast where we do a monthly
live stream where you get to vote for
who wins so you can join our comedy
writing Master Class Linked In the
description to compete in next month's
contest but without further Ado there's
only one thing left to do
and that is inhale a hot breath
with Bob
Kirk
all right
Good to Be Alive you you made it I made
it oh my gosh
how does it feel
s phenomenal
two in a row man wow wow geez what's
your secret
it's my secret just keep writing
persistence that's the secret aha that
consistent persistence yes
and you're looking sharp there Joel all
dressed up there you know it really
plays for the podcast you know I think
people can really hear how dressed up I
am right now yeah
hilarious yeah that's great thank you so
what what's your uh what's your favorite
joke from this set oh geez I think the
uh uh
this the I like my women like my change
loose oh my gosh it's so good what did
you uh what what did you do to come up
with that how did you think of that one
yeah you know what I did about
um eight drafts of this whole set right
oh my God I was looking back and Draft
when I came up with that so I just kept
it with the other drafts right like I
would look back like I know you asked me
before what you know the different the
changes and the different sets and that
but uh
um you know there was a few for sure but
it's neat to look back and see when you
come up with something right it just did
like I said the you know how many
different ways
and I found this one tough like I I
gotta be honest right
um
change it was it was difficult to write
um for sure you know so man I just keep
plugging away trying to come up with
stuff
you know and that one did that one just
kind of appear like you're just riding
and that one just popped in your head
type deal yeah yeah it said all the
change okay change there's Loose Change
there's change in your pockets there's
chain you know like do some listing
techniques you know
stuff like that you know yeah that is
the funny thing about writing is
sometimes you like you labor over a joke
to find it and then other times one kind
of appears but it is that consistency to
that gives you the opportunity to find
those magic jokes that just kind of
appear you know yeah I know it surprised
me and it made it it made me laugh so uh
and try and I gotta give a shout out to
well to you for doing this you know and
all your hard work it it is great you
know I'm enjoying the Wednesdays too to
see you live and give them some feedback
on people's jokes yeah it's fun yeah
yeah
Yoshi you know on your Tuesday if I can
make it a do it but also that you know
big shout out to to to Joan and Jack and
and Jerry quill you know uh in in uh
Jones room on Monday night 6 00 p.m and
she's there no matter the weather yeah
right so you know we get a lot done and
try to help each other for sure in there
it's great it's great feedback and and
uh input from people and then Chris
roulon you know with the Dino's in the
room and Lorna and Jones in there too
and Emmy and Andy when he can make it
he's so busy though Rory Clinton and
Bernice Sarah and Juan Carlos geez I
hope I didn't leave anybody wow you know
that's beautiful well I mean it's it's a
it's a long you know a lot of people in
this group are really dedicated like
Bobby posting the word every day you
know Emery doing the joke of the night
you know so it's great you know to have
so many supported people and and doing
all this so I I give everybody Kudos and
a big shout out out for them to keep us
I think it really does keep us motivated
in writing yeah I think I think it's up
to the individual too to keep at it you
know I mean come and go but I think it's
the consistency of uh just
doing it you know and I to be honest I
enjoy the writing you know I probably
enjoy the writing more than than
anything you know than the Performing
yeah yeah I think so
so writer for hire if anybody's looking
there you go yeah because you're because
your performance you know during the the
live stream when we played your set I
mean people were commenting on your
performance so much so it's interesting
to say you actually enjoy the writing
more than your like big performance yeah
I mean I enjoy the Performing too but
I'm only in the garage they're just
doing it yeah
yeah your sets of involve evolved over
the time we've been doing this contest I
remember there was one where you like
you run like a selfie stick and you
started it like in a tree and then you
like zoomed it down
I was gonna do that again because it was
such a nice day when I when I did this
it was beautiful sunny and the the it's
uh what is it a crab apple tree out back
right and Blossom and red I said uh and
Myrtle said why don't you do it outside
but I I was going to but the neighbor
two over was doing his roof so there was
a lot of banging going on so it was like
hilarious you know so interference you
know as far as the set so I had I was
forced inside with that one you know
well it worked out for you there yeah
yeah I think so it was fine you know
um yeah it uh it's a lot of fun I enjoy
it a lot you know well I think the thing
I mean I do enjoy performance but I find
with me
it's the learning and memorizing this
stuff I that's my biggest struggle
really to be honest you know of learning
the sets you know yeah the recording
yeah the recording I think is an
underrated part of the process of
submitting to this contest and
and I think it also you can find a lot
of new punch lines in just having to
record it over and over and over again
yeah I think I did about 10 takes on
that and it's funny that that first joke
what was it uh uh never say to your
girlfriend I'm looking for change out of
those words they were my last uh oh no
no the first one about there's 175
iterations for the word change and I'm
good and that so that was it and then I
when I did it I said I'm gonna I'm gonna
discuss or I'm gonna do every one of
them here today yeah that I found up
doing it right so yeah there is some
improv definitely so you got to leave
yourself open to to to be able to do
that right
yeah so you you had eight drafts
just writing it initially and then you
recorded the final draft 10 times and
found some new things along the way
there too yeah yeah yeah usually when I
record it too I'll find you know I'll go
too long like it's 90 supposed to be 90
seconds so this one's come in at like
140 150 you know and go oh man
what do I do do I edit do I what what's
going on here so it's just getting get I
think getting the flow of it you know
yeah and Tim Tim King said I find it
easy to write about what I'm interested
in but I find it hard to write on a
theme because my instinct is to do what
I'm not do what I'm told hilarious oh
yeah yeah any advice for Tim there
I don't know I think and you said it
earlier
it's a challenge to come up with you
know here's your theme go you know I
think it really challenges you to come
up with new stuff right and you may love
just writing I mean you can do both
right on what you want you know for part
of the day and and then work on these
little contests that you know I think
challenges you to do it you know
and you can find ways to like it may
start out as not on theme but I think
you could probably find ways to kind of
manipulate or massage it into being more
on theme in a deal or like I think it's
just I mean if he says he doesn't like
to do it or he finds it easy to write
about what he's interested in yeah I
mean what are you interested in with
change I'm sure you could find things
it's like change is just like the
jumping off point the theme is just the
inspiration like you don't have to use
the word change in your set if you don't
want to it's like
a writing exercise is like I think it's
popular in improv it's like a to c where
it's like a makes me think of B which
then makes me think of C so it's like
change could make me think of coins
which makes me think of making a minimum
wage at my job you know like and then
it's about it's inspired by change but
it's not specifically like the theme and
hear me using the word in my jokes you
know I mean like Sandy said I mean and
shout out to Jack and Sandy the
multi-greet sets great sets and and
Sandy focusing more on the the corporate
you know from that angle too yeah yeah
yeah yeah and how she reinterpreted it
into like changing underwear but then
changing like jobs like looking at
change in a bunch of different ways yeah
exactly and I know like corporately
because I used to do more corporate
stuff and they're always dealing with
change you know
it's like letting people go oh that's a
change now go and make them laugh they
just they just lost half their staff
bring up their morale go ahead yeah
let's work yeah you know so yeah I mean
there's a corporately I think there's
always change happening and then it's
funny to hear like Jack set
younger guy so he's talking about change
within his family and then he's talking
about change within his friends you know
so he was able to make change
a personal thing as well yeah yeah so uh
and it I think for everybody change can
be different yeah like you said the
different angles from uh all three of it
you probably when you and your wife
watch the sets you'll probably see
different you know
you know how people uh interpret that
and bring it up bring it off yeah we
really do enjoy it and like we really do
like look forward to it and my favorite
is when
she gets a big laugh
because it you know I mean she doesn't
laugh at anything I do so we're
definitely the Loose Change one was one
that got a um a big laugh for sure for
sure so that's good that's good I'm
happy and and you know I I always I
think I mentioned this before I always
use you know when I start these out I I
use the you know what is this one the oh
God what is it that the the free The
Source I think you mentioned it before
oh yeah that's a great website yeah yeah
for for it it sort of gives me uh in
word HIPAA word hippo is good yeah
yeah that's a good one too yeah and I
found phrases too are good right is that
a website phrases.com yeah yeah nice I
love how you printed them out I love
that we're talking about a website and
you would print it off the web page you
know I love that
I'm old school look look at look at this
all my things are printed that all eight
drafts wow I mean right hook yeah yeah
you know I I like uh I like Google Docs
it's it's great because you can I can
use it on this laptop or my desktop or
uh my phone so I I find that really
handy you know to to be able to use it
on my phone to uh if at night I wanna uh
write or like if I'm if I'm doing in
race uh you know joke of the night I can
use the phone and if I'm in bed yeah
yeah I use Google Docs too because then
you can also search if it's like if it's
um if you're like oh I knew I wrote a
joke about like such and such theme you
can then search it in Google Docs and
it'll pull it up right right or or you
think you're out shopping and something
comes up you can just you know either
and I love the feature you know being
able to talk into it and it it
you know writes it out or prints it out
to me that's that's great I mean yeah
for sure yeah that's another way to do
it yeah yeah you have to be careful
though because I think I mentioned the
uh the uh
you know I've been working on this
character and the uh 1001 ways to be
romantic right yeah I was reading in
that book about uh
um the the what is it Neil muscalia the
author of uh Born to Love right and so I
talked into that right so you know get
this book
Born to Love
is a good thing I checked it later the
next day I checked in and said porn for
love so so
yeah yeah I go wow okay
got a proofread
that really changes the context
exactly exactly
so yeah that I mean I'm just
you know using all these tools and I
actually this week this past week I did
five days of uh with think media on they
had a free challenge for about YouTube
but I haven't I've got my uh website
Bob Kirk comedy but I haven't put it
posted anything on it like on YouTube
yet I have to I have to learn to edit
first oh is yours um
oh you have oh your website meaning like
your YouTube channel oh yeah yeah sorry
not Oh I thought you meant your actual
website yeah no not yet working on it
got all these all these little changes
you know but but you um you post on Tick
Tock right yeah Tick Tock uh yeah yeah
well you can you can post what you post
on tick tock on YouTube as well okay as
like YouTube I'm surprised that think
media talk about YouTube shorts
yeah yeah they're big into that that's
doing quite well actually they showed a
lady uh I think it I think her
background is a lawyer and she made like
two hundred thousand dollars from
YouTube and it showed uh uh Instagram
she made zero
um Facebook three thousand dollars and
Tick Tock three thousand dollars she
made so there was quite a difference and
they seemed to really be posting these
shorts right for oh yeah yeah oh I mean
that's yeah yeah that's yeah that's
that's the new thing because they're
competing with like Tick Tock and
Instagram and Facebook they're trying to
get that short form content so starting
out whatever you post on Tick Tock you
can just post on YouTube and you never
know what's gonna pop off right there
but it's a great way to get the channel
started and get subscribers yeah yeah I
have to do it I told you I got I got uh
not banned from Tick Tock but one of the
videos my twerking video they it was
against community community
oh my gosh oh there he is I was I was
they had it up for a few months and then
next thing oh Community standards okay
yeah you never know yeah I mean
sometimes yeah even on like YouTube you
can get like a copyright uh notification
or something I just got one on like an
old interview I did and I have no idea
like it doesn't it's just kind of like
making you aware that someone claimed it
but it doesn't like doesn't really
affect the video or anything but yeah
that could it happens that's part of um
social media
I think too that the a big factor is to
always be learning like I've got to
learn about editing and learning about
you know with think media
um you know more about YouTube and that
you know it's always be open to to learn
like your courses or uh you know Jerry
Corley he offers a lot you know uh of
stuff so I I think
being willing uh to to do that and and
learn and keep open you know for that
because to me it's all you know it's all
good yeah you can only add to your Your
Arsenal of your for your skills and
learning so I'm I'm I'm big into that
you know that yeah
lifetime learner I guess I'd look at it
and having skin in the game really
um
it really adds incentive it really
incentivizes to learn this skill set
like you know that's that's why I mean I
I I'm taking um
a course on like writing better YouTube
titles like I'm starting out on Tuesday
like something that specific
um how to generate like good ideas and
how to write titles because YouTube's
the whole thing with title and thumbnail
that's like it's almost more important
than the actual video itself but um yeah
I'm and I'm doing that because it's like
I'm almost like paying for the
accountability to actually learn this
thing that I've been meaning to do you
know when you have skin in the game I
also retain it better because I'm like
oh well I invested in this so I want to
get my return on this investment you
know so it really makes a difference
yeah yeah so it you know it's always a
challenge to me to learn this stuff you
know
yeah yeah but like you said it's all a
process yeah yeah for sure but I do
enjoy the right I I looked at it before
like oh it's taken away from my time of
writing or you know performing to it but
I think it's coming up with a a calendar
and and doing that you know like I find
it do the right 10 if I can and and
focus on that as a nice little warm up
and write for July 11 or 12 or a couple
of hours you know and then do my other
stuff that I have to do oh yeah I'm
learning that because I started my
personal YouTube channel and I'm doing
like kind of more like video essay Style
videos and I I started with short form
and now I'm doing longer form videos now
that I've gotten to the Thousand
subscribers that's part of the
monetization is getting a thousand
subscribers and then a certain amount of
watch time so now I'm doing longer form
to get that watch time up but it takes
away like the generating ideas the
researching the scripting they're
recording like all that is taking away
from my stand-up right now but I know
long term it's there's they're going to
synergize and one's going to help the
other and whatnot but I'm I'm totally
fine with right now okay more of my
focus is actually on building this
YouTube
and not as much on my stand-up that I've
been doing for 12 years so I know long
term it's all going to come back around
but it's yeah like just pick a thing and
learn it and then it'll help strengthen
everything else you're doing
so when you did your personal YouTube
did you do a business one or a personal
one set up the the account a business
one like when I set the actual Channel
yeah
well
oh like the type of Channel
because I think they say the business
one allows you more uh you know like
without once you get the Thousand yeah
it's I mean I guess it would be the
business one then yeah I actually set it
up I've had this channel a little while
um but I like revamped it like I took
all the videos off and now I'm making it
more of this like video essay style
Channel and not like my skits and things
like that so okay
um but yeah it's I'd say it's a business
Channel yeah I'm definitely building it
to monetize it for sure right okay so if
you had different like the sa1 and your
other ones your sketches couldn't you
just do that in a playlist like do
different playlists for yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so right now I still have every
I still have these videos that I've
created in like separate playlists but
they're not um they're unlisted now
um though they're not you can't actually
see them when you come to my YouTube
channel but you can see them in the
playlists but okay this is all very new
I probably started doing this like two
months ago but um I'm very excited about
it yeah yeah I'm excited to learn about
it too just like get in there come on
stay retain it yeah and Lynn asked what
is the character you said you're
creating does he have a name
oh yeah Ned the empty nester
that'd be empty I think I showed you
this book before I wrote and you guys
see that no okay oh gotta go the other
way yep a thousand and one ways to be
romantic yeah and then at the top here
it says
worth remember oh [__]
worth memorizing oh hilarious oh man I
I've actually written about 280 pages of
jokes on this book based on this book so
it it it's like it gives you sort of a
uh uh almost like a setup basically and
then hopefully a funny bit after it you
know that sounds like a book in itself
the jokes about this topic you know yeah
it's about romances sounds very funny
yeah yeah so I'm uh you know that Ned
the empty nester and Myrtle you know so
uh yeah
I love the reference yeah someone
earlier in the live chat said they love
that you bring up uh Myrtle
yeah and I think this was the first 90
second thing where I said I think I
mentioned Myrtle a few times in in that
90 seconds you know so that was uh a
more personal view you know yeah there's
that you know so I I have fun with that
it's like I think I got a lot
yeah I'm having fun that's number one
you know that's what's gonna make it
sustainable and whatever is just having
fun it does just because something's fun
doesn't mean it'll be easy but whatever
you're doing making sure you're having
fun while doing it it'll just make the
whole experience more pleasurable and
sustainable oh yeah for sure if you're
not having fun why do it yes amen yeah
well where um where would you like
people to gosh I mean you've won two
months in a row so people definitely go
back and listen to your other interviews
You've Won do you know how many times
you've won now you don't know it's
several yeah it's several but um what
where would you like people to go or
like to check you out well there's
nothing on YouTube yet I guess uh
Facebook
post those shorts on YouTube just throw
them up there it's like it's like a tick
tock really but but it's like you said I
need to put a uh a title and a thumbnail
I gotta learn how to do that right for
shorts you don't need a thumbnail
no um and then like title is just like
yeah whatever it's like a short I just
put the on Tick Tock I just put the
theme like change and then it disappears
in 15 seconds you know whatever the oh
right yeah yeah yeah
that all works for shorts yeah you don't
need like a a thumbnail or
um on YouTube are they only a minute
they're only a minute I think so yeah
yeah because these are 90 seconds well I
was gonna I was gonna do the uh you call
it the uh uh 90 seconds with Bob right
and and look back I think I don't know
at least there's at least 12 that I've
done so
and put them on YouTube yeah the shorts
are like you said a minute so but you
could break them into two so it could be
like jokes about change part one jokes
about change part two you could do like
part one and part two so if someone
sees part one and is like oh I really
like that I wonder where part two is and
then they go to your Channel
and can watch Part Two And subscribe
from there oh okay because yeah this
this empty nester I was just going to do
one joke at a time so if you have one
minute I mean some jokes are longer some
are shorter you know whatever I can do
so I was planning to do that in the
shorts you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's all worth trying yeah that's that's
that name of the game is yeah you throw
it out there and see what sticks and
then do more of what sticks you know I
think any any social media
comedian I've interviewed that has like
hundreds of thousands or millions of
followers
they got it by just doing a bunch of
things and then whatever worked they
just did more of that you know but it
took a lot of testing and trial and
error right now
and then they find what works and then
they double down on it yeah
I don't have that much time though
no don't say that Bob you got plenty of
time fam you're working it you're
working it it's gonna work for sure
yeah I love it anyway
well is there is there anything else you
want the world to know here Bob before
we land the plane I don't know just like
uh go to The Tick Tock or Facebook I
think on Facebook the person ones one
one uh Bob with one oh and then I did
open a Facebook more business one Bob
Kirk comedy but I don't have any hardly
any viewers on there at all it's more
more the personal one right cool and
then and then whenever I do my
my YouTube one when I got a launch you
know
so I don't know I'm doing a couple of
corporates you know but that's for
corporate right I want to do the funeral
directors of the GTA greater Toronto
area and I want to be able to do it in
uh from inside a casket
hilarious
like uh like you know like a week like a
casket that's up right you know and
deliver my stuff from there I think I
don't know if they'll go for it but
anyway there is
huh I love it yeah the past two weeks of
the podcast have been about corporate
shows so um definitely some good
resources for anyone else looking to get
into corporate work yeah for sure
very nice well Bob it's always a
pleasure my friend congratulations
um you've done it again buddy so I'm so
happy and grateful for you
and when are you dropping the next theme
it's always the first Friday of the
month so it'll be this upcoming Friday
all right yeah first Friday of the month
and then people get two weeks to ride it
yeah
I know two weeks is a long time I think
I but I when you're getting more
submissions right so that's good I know
yeah we're getting more submissions and
the sets were like better because they
had time to ferment you know and people
had time to take them to the stage if
they wanted to and things like that so
it just I mean the whole goal of the set
is to like give people accountability to
write more jokes so if that if that
requires two weeks instead of one week
so they're not like hating themselves
trying to cram it in then that's um that
that's what matters so yeah we changed
it from one week to two weeks and it
seems to
make sure that's better you know
yeah people aren't getting as anxious
right yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
nice all right well Joe
as always Bob it's a pleasure my friend
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thanks Joe for all you do and
and uh it's always a pleasure and uh
Sandy and Jack great job keep it up
let's see you back next month let's do
it Bob's going for the three-peat next
month now go for the hat trick man
well congrats Bob and um I'm excited for
you man keep up the great work okay
thanks Joel all right have a good day
buddy bye-bye bye bye everybody
bye
yeah
we did it
we did it oh my gosh
how fun
oh yeah and Jerry said corporate shows
your goal too well the podcast the one
coming out tomorrow and then one from
last week are great resources about how
to get into corporate comedy so
definitely worth it there go check those
out there
and um great job congrats to um Jack and
Sandy as well and everyone that
submitted great sets and uh congrats to
Bob
and uh we'll be back next month with
another one my friend
so um go join our comedy writing
masterclass if you want to get involved
in next month's contest
but until then my friends I love you so
much
you all have a good day out there we'll
see you on the other side
bye
[Music]